[Musique]
pas
ou laisse tomber tout le monde s'en
va c'est pour ça que je disais il faut
l'effacer je
recommencezy
paril
ou là il faut vraiment que tu le fasses
au télé très serré de cette distance là
et tu vas aller voir commre sur l'eau tu
vois ça va être très joli tu voisre sens
regarde tu vois attends ils V nous voir
passer comme ça ils vont se voilà oh les
jein sur la file du pont
là là là là pour moi c'est beaucoup
beaucoup trop et beaucoup trop petit tu
vois moi j'ai envie de les voir très bas
sur l'eau en verticale par au-dessus là
c'est haut et tu prends prends la route
et tu tu la suis tout le long et tu
découvres les trucs ou alors tu es assez
bas et tu es au télé comme on vient de
faire mais tu es vraiment tu vois il
vont t découvrir en silhouette sur l'eau
tu vas all voir travailler tu vois on
coupe alors on fait quoi on fait comme
ça on part dans l'autre
sens ça-ce que tu peux tu veux faire
comment là comme ça comme ça d'accord
faire comme ça tu
veuxok
car groupe intéressant
r C'est
be
serer voilà très dou doucement doucement
doucement perdu
le
coup dessus c'est joli au MO plus serré
sur les de pont quo tu
vois ça tourne ça tour c'est marrant C
de pont anciens et nouveau doucement
très
doucement ça c'est marrant les deux P là
à côté de l'autre c'est rigolo
qu'est-ce qui B les mecs en bas
le savon le
truc en TR de laver en
vertical
er pas dedans là regarde en dessousè de
bordel de ce qui se passe en dessous
tuas même pas des bateaux je sais pase
regarde mon
[Musique]
do qui passe tous les gens tout le long
qui sont en train de laver c'est
vachement beau
ça ta gauche la super beau doucement
doucement le tenir je le tenir ah je
sais pas metzv d'accord préér que lui a
sa caméra plutô que toi tu bouge pas
c'est possible un filet
magnifique un grand filet dans la
rivière ta caméra tu un peu ded attends
OK
pas sûr du
[Musique]
point de mecs en bleu qui vont arriver
avec des avec des chèvres qui vont
traverser le pont sont encore un peu
loin tuas super beau
ouis en train de tirer des
chèbres le bleu est
[Musique]
magnifique il nous regarde encore
du
[Musique]
Diable et le mec regardean qui tire sa
charrette de FO là sur le nouveau pont
ah
[Musique]
ouais là tu as de la vie
làin savais bien qu'il y avait un pont
comme ça qu' fait une photo sur le Dakar
je comprenais pas pourquoi je trouvais
pas il y a une be là-dessus c'est
[Musique]
formidable
pas mal ça non
bien attends ça
oui juste en dessous de toi beaucoup en
avant du pont dans l'eau il y a des
bonnes femmes qui lavent c'est assez
beau quand tu as fini ce plan là c'est
en dessous de l'hélicoptère c'est
vertical tu le vois Franck c'est pas mal
tu verras quand quand tu auras fini
[Musique]
çaas des bonnes femmes au bord de
l'eau
dans l'autre sens
maintenant pour le montage qu est le
choix on va le
faire oh merde de
merde
tu continues encore tu verras il y a un
courant avec de AC de l'eau c'est assz
joli j
ça o est-ce qu'elles sont ces bar jeis
pas où il est
là ah voilà voilà continue continue à
droite continue à droite encore
pas
[Musique]
c'est marrant V de la vie
làdessus continue continue tu vas voir
le courant il y a un mec qui pêche avec
un
filet l' ramassé son
filet j'adore ce plan
[Musique]
là
joli ça tout ça vachement
[Musique]
bien reg regarde comme c'est beau
ça
là tu vas arriver dans un gros bordel de
gens c'est dangereux ce qu'ils font là
pourqui regarde il y a un bout du Bond
qui est
effondré
oh si tu continues tu V en voir encore
plein d'autres encore à
droite un peu
peut-être cette caméra c'est quelque
chose
de euh le point là combien de di j'ai
l'impression d'être vraiment mais on est
à 12 c'est quoi ça c'estécran
trop grand trop grand pourir
bien ok
c c'est bon
stph
peu
loinpr j'enis un autre plus serré
comm
pas vas-y monte on voit tout quand même
te
plaîtir l'ombre
non
et apr va s'en faire un pareil mais très
serré en pendanton hauteur on va aller
voir les concombres làbas ok pant qu'on
y est ça vous va ou pas vous voulez
continuer làdessuse terminer ce qu'on
avait dit fait uneutut ser qu'on est là
tu
veux concombres
50 m à
gauche comment là tu es trop large là tu
vois c'est pas
tu peux faire une séquence tous les
[Musique]
gens tu termines ton plan après on va se
mettre pareil et là je vais taper
serr
d'accord
là on peut finir en statique sur l'île
làbas don parla qui voulait là c'est à
gauche du reste à gauche reste à gauche
à gauche à gauche tu le truc blanc le
linge qui sèche juste à gauche tuir les
gens voilà tu DESS et je m'arrête dessus
d'accord
ok allez comme ça remets-toi en place
rrae le camion on y
Vaour c'est bien d'être comme ça tout à
l'heure les gens sont sont sur l'eau on
a raté le
camion regarde le cheval regarde le
cheval regarde ça c'est marrant voilà
voilà
voilà reste
sur als fa unre sens peut-être doucement
doucement doucement PR
est le temps de repartir à droite mais
après il va y avoir des BR après il va y
avoir des embr douement à droitetion
bateau par le en dessous il rien ch là à
droite à droite à droite plutôt va à
droite va à droite va à droite sur
l'eau Ji quand les gens sont vraiment
pas ça gauche droite et droite gauche le
choix vas-y vas-y tu as le choix tu as
le choix vas-y doucement dou je peux pas
plus doucement sinon ça va pulser et
tout on est
c
ça
regard
ok quoi
d'A la camé ok je préfère tu règles
comme ça ta vitesse c'est
non c'est pas
terrible
merci plus
dedans plus en B tu vois plus en B par
rapport à la caméra voilà pasas rien à
droite tu vois
plus pas es trop que tu prends pas le
champ à gauche ok voilà comme ça voilà
to c'est plus beau comme ça ok allez on
vasy enfin non c'est
vas-y oua on refait non on le refait
attends bouge pas bouge pas voilà comm
c'est bien c'est c'est le chemin qui
tout
démoli di plus comme ça en diagonal sur
l'écran tu voisordachement plus beau
comme ça voilà voilà VO c'est super beau
ça pas contre jour
mais
c'est plus beau à faire à la caméra qu'
l'hélicoptère
ça en dessous c'est incroyable
[Musique]
gr
ouais c'est
pas c'est moi regarde regarde euh
oui attends ouais contre jour tu ça va
briller dans tous les sens ça que tu
recules un peu